sacked by the Prime Minister but many
are asking if he should have gone
earlier on Monday Rishi sunak ordered an
investigation into allegations
conservative party chairman Nadeem
zahawi paid six million dollars
including a penalty to settle a dispute
with the tax authorities known as hmrc
now he's written to zahari saying
following the completion of the
independent advisors investigation the
findings of which he has shared with us
both it is clear that there's been a
serious breach of the ministerial code
the report criticizes zahawi for several
failings he didn't mention an hmrc
investigation started in 2021 in his
register of interests until last summer
that was after then prime minister Boris
Johnson had made him Chancellor of the
exchequer last October when Rishi sunak
appointed him party chair and Minister
without portfolio so how we failed to
mention he'd paid a penalty but speaking
on Thursday the Prime Minister insisted
he acted as soon as any concerns were
raised
well when I appointed nadimsa harwi to
his current job no issues were raised
with me about that appointment it's
really important to say but because
Nadeem zahali himself put a statement
into the public domain and there was
other reporting there are questions to
answer and that's why I asked the
independent advisor to conduct an
investigation to fully establish the
facts but the opposition labor party
says it's not good enough and it was
always clear that the Prime Minister was
going to have to act it was just a
matter of time but I think it does speak
to his weakness that it's taken him so
long to act but this isn't just about
Nadim zahawi we had swella bravaman who
also brought the ministerial called and
then was appointed back into government
as Home Secretary a cross-party
committee in Parliament concluded that
reappointment set a dangerous precedent
when it comes to how breaches of the
ministerial code are dealt with now
questions are being asked about how much
Rishi sunak knew of Nadim zahawi's
investigation by the tax authorities and
when
still on the horizon an investigation
into numerous complaints of bullying by
Deputy Prime Minister Dominic Raab
and a parliamentary inquiry into whether
Boris Johnson misled the House of
Commons over drinking sessions held
during pandemic lockdowns known as the
partygate Scandal the Prime Minister
took off his promising integrity and
accountability those themes won't be
disappearing for a while Nadeem Barber
Al Jazeera London